you're welcome to this blitz game
playing black against and i am from from
where suspect yeah I suspected something
around yeah this is united arab emirates
i was expecting something from this area
those flags often look a bit like that
ok so the bogo with a five but Sam has
mentioned numerous times subject of a
book that I'm writing so let's see get
him a three earlier this is a bit
uncommon to have the smooth plate as so
early okay but it's still nothing
special we am now transposed to to the
names oh it's quincy to quincy to 196
just by a transposition taking only five
we are taking only five is always an
option for white mainly in positions we
have the ponies on e3 but because now
you are simply have weakened your your
default square and long castles are some
really uncommon I mean it's not quite
sure what what the king is so supposed
to do on c1 okay but let's see how how
it continues yeah I would have taken
anyway so this just amounts to a loss of
tempo my ideas now nitey 694 and have a
brilliant night on before this gets
kicked
I don't want you to exchange your Bishop
for my night and now I'll I'll manage to
go to d4 yeah I expected rook t5
actually to get at least a bit of
counter play this is now very one-sided
I just have this excellent knight on d4
and white white basically has a ruined
position
so how to continue there are many
interesting ways Queen c5 even as some
as possible he's not really threatening
on a five I have night be three winning
a piece on this so maybe maybe continue
until strengthen the position a bit
takes on a five as mentioned night be
three and black wins apiece okay
question is some what is the strongest
and continuation my castle short maybe I
should should play this first Bishop g4
yeah okay this is no everything's in
order again now I can just castle castle
short and play next move be five before
a black is simply a quicker on the
queenside supported by it by the Knights
hmm
so how to do this maybe unless let's
spend one move here so on edge 6i have
g6 with no I'm direct threat my tension
our screen before we are going before
and Queen a 4g 6i i just retreat the
king
the exchanges on before that's a for
hanging I mean I certainly didn't play
this the best wave there's no no
question but i still hope it's it's
enough to win the game not winning would
be heartbreaking after the relief
enormously a bad news that he played so
what's this
if I take how does he save the king I
don't see it let's take it I simply
don't see how he saves to save the king
coming if a 2 a 1 B 2 and so on
maybe Bishop d3 yeah Bishop d3 Bishop d3
to be one and talk about ugly chess but
it's may be working have the Queen the
Queen to do the same here come on let's
let's let's do this now before i get i
get mated i can also take on e 2 and
then give the check and take be to then
and he cannot play clip you one anyway
so just nonsense what I'm calculating
here if I go here then I will take on g6
with the check the Sun it's also quite
ok probably
King d2 just night before so i can take
with the check in and then no no no no
what now
night deform he still has got rooked he
too
come on oh let's let's do this keep it
simple threatening on f2 and threatening
923 so I have a ton of extra points and
I certainly won't get mated or something
in this position let's move to the de
poncy em a and B pawn yeah what you did
here simply give me this D foursquare
what does exchange and then allowing all
this that the bishop is exchanged and
now that's the rare case of two nights
completely dominating two bishops adhere
around here Black is some strategically
winning but i didn't i didn't play this
to grade he really got got a bit of play
now maybe just just rook rook to 896 or
something it was it was rather rather
shaky but yeah the computer gives me a
winning advantage but it felt a bit a
bit shaky nevertheless yeah thanks for
watching